[Music]
are you ready to see some moves like
Jagger at Super Bowl 53 I say yes please
cuz that means an Adam Levine Kevin
Frazier in New York what you know cat
well Nancy that's the news that has
everyone buzzing and we have learned
that maroon 5 is in for the big game
[Music]
it's a dream come true for Adam a source
tells ET maroon5 has always wanted to
play the Super Bowl halftime
in fact we're told it's one of Adam
Levine's biggest goals I think the band
would be like thrilled to do it Adam
practically paying for the epic gig on
Howard Stern in 2015 when the band was
rumoured to be in the running for half
time I know that we're like probably on
a short list
we very actively want to play the Super
Bowl Nancy sat down with Adam ahead of
the band's current tour the red pill
blues tour so what can we expect in the
tour we don't like to overdo it so you
know keep it to a minimum keep just the
band on stage and just kick as much as
we can and the timing works the band has
a big gap in its schedule in the
beginning of February
leaving them wide open to perform at
halftime and of course we've all come to
expect halftime collaborations and the
band can deliver they've recently worked
with cardi B and scissor making this all
the more interesting is that this season
Super Bowl airs on CBS and voice coach
Adam Levine is closely associated with
rival network NBC here's how Adam
addressed that I don't know what their
motivations behind those decisions are
other than they probably want to get the
best person for the job I guess
look as we all know the NFL is never
going to confirm anything this early in
fact the league released a statement
today quote we are continuing to work
with Pepsi on our plans but do not have
any announcements to make on what will
be another epic show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]